let's talk about your your movie UHF
okay you when did that come out with you
80 89 89 and there's some it's become
this cult classic and there are
different scenes in it that really pop
for people but in one of the scenes you
ate something that I I believe you came
up with or one of the writers that
worked on it came up with which is a
Twinkie Weiner sandwich yes
a Twinkie meter so much is something
that you invented and you take it is
what it sounds like you take a Twinkie
cut it and then you put I think we have
a picture of one right here that is a
Twinkie Twinkie Weiner stone and what I
would say when I heard it it sounded
disgusting but when I saw that photo I
don't know why you made that reaction I
was kind of drawn to it I really was if
you know I I did think of that like 3
o'clock in the morning that was one of
my delirious ideas that is that when
your ideas happens really mostly yeah
it's like that your brainwave for you
know undulating at a specific rate and
and you come up with a really bizarre
idea it's not the most creative period
for me but it was kind of weird because
I came up with that odd idea and now 30
years later they have 20 weirdo sandwich
parties you know it's become a thing if
people actually and have you talked to
anybody about how it tastes you know
everybody and I can say the from
experience and it's been a carbureted by
many people over the years it's not as
bad as you'd think
having said that not very good yeah I've
had critics say that not as bad as
you've heard it's Christmas a big deal
in the Yankovic household Oh might not
well my daughter's very into Christmas I
mean we'll all holiday like Arbor Day
let's pound some trees you know like
Indian holiday she was very excited it's
very strange
yeah and Arbor Day I mean I'm not a
monster but I'm not like super into
Christmas when I was a kid I was really
into Christmas and my my folks weren't
certainly weren't dirt-poor but there
was like Laura middle-class so we didn't
have a lot of money for like extravagant
present so I did practical things like
you know notebook paper you know you
wait you for Christmas you'd get
notebook yeah but like a college ruled
kind of like the really good stuff oh
and for a second I felt sorry for you
household words like you know why you
want to listen to I don't want to buy a
record you can listen to the radio and
what you want to go to the movies it'll
be on TV in eight years with commercials
just wait you know so like if I wanted
to get like I wanted a twister game on
here because I was like a big thing one
year and my parents instead I got a
bedsheet and they painted large circles
on it and colored them in and then you
could play twister yeah like you know we
didn't want to give our money to the man
and we made our own twister game right
did it did you actually try it out I was
pretty good at how I was born without a
skeleton so I was able to really those
things just get in the way here is this
true there's a Weird Al Art Show yeah
it's coming out that's it gallery
what is it 1988 right now actually it's
going on right now and this is they've
curated you have very devoted fans and
very talented fans and they've curated a
sort of an art show of the art that your
fans have made that's right yeah so if
you want to take us through some of this
is there anything we can take a look at
I think we have a picture I think we
have three examples look at that that is
fantastic
oh that is fantastic and there's another
one I'm sure coming up soon and Wow
very impressive and then you look and
still do sometimes yeah is that your
look of surprise that look that's my
look of being awake very good so people
can go see that show where is the show
exactly gallery 1988 I think it's 70 308
Melrose but it could be wrong okay and
if people want to buy the the shirt the
shirt is available I think that's a
weird al' calm as we speak
I just did that for you excited I I just
love having this up this is so long the
only guy I know who brings this with you
when you come wherever we go